als jij de verdurende dag steeds dubbele cijfers ziet
dan is deze video voor jou
cijfers als 3 3 3 1 1 1 5 5 5
maar ook voor nummers zoals
Uhm nummers en op de trouw zoals 1
8 1 2 5 2 3 4 3 enzovoorts
wat betekent dat nou eigenlijk
3 dingen betekenen meestal
want er is natuurlijk veel meer
maar laten we ons eerst
focussen op deze volgende 3 redenen
de eerste is Wil je laten weten wij zijn bij je
dat kunnen je gitsen zijn je engelen
hoge energieën
en ze willen je op dat moment laten weten
dat waar je ook doorheen gaat op dat moment
zij zijn bij jou
tweede is als bevestiging
als je bepaalde gedachten had op dat moment
of je twijfelt aan jezelf
willen jou
gitsen of engelen je laten weten dat waar je aan denkt
goed is als laatste aandacht
ze willen je ergens voor waarschuwen
of 1 bevestiging geven dat wat jij voelt echt waar is
dus probeer je in zo'n moment goed na te gaan
bij jezelf waar dacht ik aan
aan wie dacht ik en voelde dit goed of niet goed
dus negatief of positief
laat me weten in de comments welke
nummers jij vaak ziet